alors Mesdames et Messieurs avant de
vous donner la parole et en application
de l'article 6 de l'ordonnance numéro
58-1100 du 17 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires je vais vous demander de
prêter serment de dire la vérité toute
la vérité rien que la vérité et donc je
vais vous demander si vous
permettez de le faire dans ce sens là on
va commencer par Monsieur Souillot et
puis ensuite
suivre l'ensemble de la table si vous
pouvez simplement lever la main droite
donc première chose il conviendra
d'appuyer sur le micro levez la main
droite et de dire je le jure ensuite
évidemment à nouveau débrancher le micro
pour que la puisque quand un micro est
branché personne suivante ne peuvent pas
s'exprimer pour que vous puissiez
évidemment prêter serment donc si vous
pouvez successivement
lever la main droite et dire je le jure
après avoir activé votre micro je vous
en remercie
je le jure
merci beaucoup et donc je permets déjà
de vous donner la parole pour que vous
puissiez évidemment réagir à
ses premières interrogations et puis on
va peut-être justement commencer par par
Monsieur Souillot mais il semble
évidemment important que toutes les
organisations syndicales puissent
s'exprimer donc je vous en prie Monsieur
le Secrétaire général
merci monsieur le président
alors on n'a pas l'habitude de de parler
comme ça dans les organisations
syndicales puisqu'il y a une loi sur la
représentativité en règle générale on
commence par la première organisation la
deuxième et la troisième donc
si ça compte si ça convient mais les
autres camarades
je n'ai pas de pardonnez-nous l'objectif
est pas du tout mais de de la story une
quelconque hiérarchie même si vous avez
parfaitement raison il y a certains
d'usages que vous pouvez avoir voilà
donc qui sont des usages définis par la
loi en plus donc
donc depuis
le 19 janvier nous avons à organiser 12
manifestations
ces manifestations ont mis des millions
de personnes dans la rue
dans un esprit
festif de manifestations
ce que nous n'avions pas connu les uns
ou les autres depuis quelques années les
chiffres sont historiques
pour la plupart du nombre de
manifestants mais en plus de cela dans
les cortèges syndicaux
il y avait de la musique des chansons
des revendications bien entendu mais pas
autre chose que des revendications et
tout cela nous avons organisé nos
manifestations comme nous les organisons
toujours
la loi nous imposait de déposer une
demande de manifestation
alors je vais parler pour Paris et
c'était pareil sur le territoire
national en lien avec la préfecture de
police nous déposions avec un référent
pour la manifestation et des référents
par organisation syndicale qui signait
la demande d'autorisation de
manifestation
ces manifestations se sont bien
déroulées
à l'intérieur des cortèges syndicaux et
vous l'avez rappelé la liberté de
manifester et le droit à la
manifestation et à la grève c'est un
droit fondamental de notre Constitution
le maintien de l'ordre public
de ce qui peut se passer autour des
manifestations c'est ce n'est pas de la
responsabilité des organisations
syndicales donc quand nous déposions
nos demandes de manifestation
ce que vous appelez service d'ordre pour
nous ce sont des militants volontaires
qui tiennent la corde où on encadre le
cortège syndical ce n'est pas autre
chose
donc dans les questionnaires que vous
nous aviez envoyé c'est comment vous les
recruter comment vous les former comment
vous les équipez
ils ont une carte à force Ouvrière je
vais parler pour moi et voilà le mode de
recrutement on passe pas par un cabinet
ni quoi que ce soit
ils font pas club de boxe le soir et
tir au LBD le lendemain matin
donc ce sont des militants autour du
carré de tête et dans les carrés de
chaque organisation nous avions mis en
place une corde ce qui permettait
délimiter le cortège des organisations
syndicales pour nous ces manifestations
elles se sont bien déroulées
et ce qui s'est passé
autour ou avant
mais pour nous ça alors avec les
violences que nous avons condamné les
uns et les autres il y a pas de il y a
pas de sujet
mais souvent dans la presse on ne parle
plus que de ce qui s'est passé autour et
on ne parle plus de la revendication
donc pour nous organisations syndicale
pour mon organisation syndicale les
manifestations on les a organisées comme
nous les organisons habituellement
les membres qui tenaient la corde
étaient adhérents en Force ouvrière et
avait juste une carte pour le
recrutement et on n'est pas passé par un
cabinet
de conseils ou quoi que ce soit sur ce
sujet donc c'était des manifestations
comme nous n'en avions pas connu ou peu
connu regardez le 1er mai où nous étions
pour la première fois toutes les
organisations syndicales et nous
n'avions jamais mis autant de monde dans
la rue et ce premier mai c'est bien
déroulé
merci je vous remercie
la parole à Madame
[Musique]
pour la CFDT
donc je reprends quelques éléments que
vous avez permis d'avoir quelques propos
liminaires et puis je répondrai bien
entendu au deux
ensembles de questions que vous avez que
vous avez posé donc vous avez souhaité
convoquer et entendre la CFDT par la
voix de sa secrétaire général ainsi que
l'ensemble des organisations et donc
nous répondons à cette à cette
convocation
une petite introduction avant de
répondre pour préciser je pense que
c'est important le périmètre de nos
prises de parole et au regard notamment
des travaux de cette commission vous
avez souhaité nous entendre sur
l'expérience des organisations
syndicales représentatives à propos des
manifestations et rassemblements
qu'elles avaient organisé au cours de la
période définie des difficultés
qu'avaient fait naître la multiplication
des dégradations en marge des cortèges
régulièrement déclarées comme le cours
de mouvement spontanés et de leur
relation avec les autorités publiques
dans l'exercice de leur action
vendicative la CFDT que je représente a
donc cette capacité de faire part de son
expérience sur les seules manifestations
bien entendu et rassemblement
organisé par elle-même ou avec
l'intersyndical pendant l'ensemble de la
mobilisation contre le projet de réforme
des retraites cette expérience elle
porte donc sur l'ensemble des
manifestations organisées du 19 janvier
au 6 juin 2023 à la fois dans l'ensemble
des sur l'ensemble des villes de France
y compris les plus petites puisque c'est
une caractéristique de cette
mobilisation
outre le fait qu'il est un nombre de
manifestants inégalés le nombre de
villes dans lesquelles se sont organisés
les rassemblements et des manifestations
est également lui aussi extrêmement
important
les règles que nous nous sommes fixées à
la CFDT c'est le respect de la loi
déclaration en préfecture ou en mairie
de toute manifestation au rassemblement
gestion d'un dispositif de service
d'ordre en coordination avec les
responsables des forces de l'ordre notre
responsabilité et bien d'assurer la
sécurité des biens et des personnes du
carré de tête à la fin du cortège et
donc les violences sur lesquelles vous
enquêtez ce sont situés en dehors de ce
périmètre la CFDT a toujours dénoncé les
violences en marge des manifestations et
des rassemblements
et je voudrais souligner comme la fait
Frédéric que l'une des caractéristiques
aussi de ces cortèges c'était une très
bonne tenue de manifestations Pacifique
massive dans tout le pays avec des
altercations qui ont été peu nombreuses
et le fait de groupuscules
et je souhaite comme vous l'avez fait
monsieur le Président rappelez une
évidence la liberté de manifester est
une liberté fondamentale à laquelle nous
sommes toutes et tous ici
particulièrement attachée pour répondre
un peu plus précisément à l'ensemble des
éléments que vous avez soulignés en
introduction
de notre point de vue
la procédure donc on travaille dans le
cas de la préparation d'une
manifestation dans le cadre d'une
procédure de déclaration
qui a fait l'objet d'une modification en
2019 qui permet d'identifier le ou les
responsables de la manifestation ainsi
que le temps légal d'occupation de la
voie publique de préciser les moyens
utilisés pour le bon déroulement de la
manifestation et d'obliger à maintenir
un lien étroit avec ses autorités
préfectorales
pour les manifestations en Île-de-France
et dans la capitale les relations de
notre responsable du service d'ordre et
de la sécurité CFDT sont régulières avec
le service dédié la direction de l'ordre
public et de la circulation mais aussi
avec les responsables de la préfecture
de police et le préfet de police
lui-même si nécessaire les échanges ont
été globalement satisfaisants pour la
période de janvier à juin
satisfaisant parce que chacun est resté
dans sa mission pour l'autorité
préfectorale autorisée et permettent le
bon fonctionnement de la manifestation
pour les organisations syndicales la
gestion des services d'ordre
les les échanges avec les forces de
l'ordre sont également assurés par une
un responsable de cette de cette de
liaison pardon le dispositif de liaison
et d'information appareil également
lui-même
suffisant
nous avons pu constater leur de violence
entre les forces de l'ordre et les
mouvances contestataires à l'occasion
desquels le caractère s'est retrouvé
sous le coup de l'une des deux parties
il est apparu nécessaire donc de
maintenir un lien direct avec les
décideurs de l'usage des forces de
l'ordre pour éviter tout incident
complémentaire
en ce qui concerne les
services d'ordre le service d'ordre de
la CFDT pour préciser également quels
sont nos missions
protéger les militants de la CFDT dans
un cortège qui est constitué et assurer
la protection avec les services d'ordre
des autres organisations syndicales la
protection du carré de tête à savoir les
responsables politiques des différentes
organisations et la bonne marche du
cortège conformément à la déclaration
préalable en préfecture du point de
départ et au point d'arrivée qui ont été
déclarées le service d'ordre est
constitué de militants volontaires
qui sont accompagnés au sein de chaque
organisation
qui constitue donc l'ensemble des
services d'ordre des organisations
en ce qui concerne les relations
services d'ordre et forces de l'ordre
comme je disais tout à l'heure sont
seuls les responsables du service
d'ordre sont à même d'échanger avec les
responsables du maintien de l'ordre avec
un lien direct
avec ce qu'on appelle un officier de
liaison
voilà
très bien je vous remercie parce qu'on
va passer
à la CGT donc
la parole monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les parlementaires la CGT
répond aujourd'hui à cette convocation
comme on répond toujours aux
sollicitations de nos institutions
républicaines pour contribuer au débat
permettre l'action du législateur mais
je voulais pointer quelques
interrogations d'abord la première c'est
l'insistance avec laquelle vous avez
souhaité entendre nominativement les
premiers premières dirigeantes des
organisations syndicales sachant que vos
secrétariat nous ont rappelé de façon
très virulente le risque d'une amende de
7500 euros et de deux ans
d'emprisonnement en cas de non
présentation
ce qui nous a semblé un peu baroque
alors que notre organisation avait
immédiatement dit être à disposition
pour répondre à vos questions techniques
en proposant par exemple que
l'administrateur de la CGT Laurent brun
se présente étant donné que c'est lui
qui a la charge politique de
l'organisation de ces questions et que
notre responsable de la LS notre
accompagnement sécurité Sylvain Bernard
ici présent se présente également donc
acte nous sommes là mais c'est vrai que
comme vous le savez la rentrée est
chargée avec de nombreuses négociations
qui concernent très largement les
salariés que ça soit la Gire Carco la
question de l'assurance chômage ou
encore la pénibilité de nombreuses
luttes sur le terrain comme sur la
question des salaires ou comme vous le
savez c'est maintenant un tiers des
Françaises et des Français qui disent ne
plus manger trois repas par jour et donc
nous aurions avec plaisir échanger avec
les parlementaires sur ces sujets qui
semblent peut-être plus de l'ordre des
secrétaire généraux des organisations
deuxième interrogation sur les objectifs
même de votre commission d'enquête sur
les groupuscules et les violences en
marge et manifestations sachant que nous
sommes des organisations syndicales qui
appellent comme l'ont dit mes homologues
à manifest des salariés et les retraités
en nombre et donc nous ne sommes
absolument pas concernés par les
groupuscules
et la responsabilité elle incombe
d'abord au pouvoir public de les gérer
et de sécuriser la voie publique
nous avons également une interrogation
parce que on s'est rendu compte que nous
n'avions pas toutes et tous reçus le
même questionnaire et que dans celui qui
a été adressé à la CGT j'avais quelques
questions bonus
notamment un sujet qui apparaît sur les
actions de lutte décidées et organisées
par les salariés eux-mêmes dans leur
profession comme dans l'énergie par
exemple donc on s'est interrogé sur
est-ce que ça signifiait que vous
considériez que nous faisions partie des
des groupuscules alors que l'ensemble
des organisations syndicales tout
ensemble compte plus de d'adhérents que
l'ensemble des organisations politiques
dernière interrogation le périmètre
temporel que vous retenez
avec une commission d'enquête qui porte
sur le 16 mars au 3 mai alors que notre
mobilisation comme l'ont rappelé
Marylise et Frédéric on a commencé le 19
janvier
et donc ce qui se passe le 16 mars c'est
l'utilisation du 49-3 utilisation du
49-3 dont il a découlé comme nous
l'avions dit les organisations
syndicales l'ont dit rappeler martelez
c'est pour ça que nous avons jusqu'au
bout exhorté le président de la
République a laissé le Parlement voter
en disant que l'utilisation du 49-3 face
à une telle mobilisation sociale
forcément ça susciterait la colère que
nous condamnions mais voilà
et donc
les la colère qui s'est exprimée dans la
rue elle peut évidemment pas être
dissociée du passage en force qui a été
choisi par le gouvernement contre le
Parlement à l'époque
ce passage en force il s'est accompagné
d'une hausse répressive qui a été
condamnée par exemple par la Commissaire
aux Droits de l'Homme du Conseil de
l'Europe
pour que nous puissions avec sur le
rapporteur en tout cas répondre aux
trois points que vous évoqué et puis
ensuite on va dans dans les dans les
éléments de réponse concernant
l'insistance je crois qu'à un moment
donné je l'ai dit de manière liminaire
pour nous les travaux doivent se
terminer en fin du mois les auditions
doivent se terminer fin septembre il y a
peut-être eu un peu d'insistance parce
que oui il est nécessaire que ça puisse
se faire dans un délai raisonnable il
nous n'avons pas pu le faire en juillet
d'ailleurs parce que l'une ou l'autre
organisation nous avait indiqué que
c'était compliqué à faire donc voilà
c'est une interaction assez habituelle
et je pense que il est normal que voilà
il puisse y avoir si nécessaire aussi un
rappel du cadre et en tout cas les
administrateurs de nationale à ce titre
font leur travail concernant le
comment dire les objectifs même je
rappelle je l'ai dit de manière
préliminaire mais je le rappelle une
nouvelle fois l'objectif pour nous est
de faire en sorte que l'on puisse
garantir l'État de droit dans un état de
droit il doit être possible de
manifester librement mais encore une
fois ce à quoi nous avons assisté au
cours des derniers mois c'est le fait
que ces manifestations devenaient de
plus en plus difficiles et à partir du
moment où vous avez des expressions très
fortes de violence et bien cela peut
contrecarrer l'exercice de ce droit et
donc il nous semblait qu'il était
important que les organisations
syndicales qui justement peuvent être
amenés à faire usage de de ce droit à
manifester et bien puisse s'exprimer à
ce sujet concernant la question
spécifique qui concerne la CGT oui nous
avons été amenés à nous déplacer à
Bordeaux on nous a signalés une
situation tout à fait particulière qui
concerne votre organisation syndicale et
donc il est tout à fait légitime mais
enfin je laisserai monsieur le
rapporteur répondent puisque c'est lui
qui comment dire supervise ce travail
autour des questionnaires mais en tout
cas il nous a semblé légitime de poser
une question spécifique puisque il y a
eu une situation spécifique concernant
votre organisation quant au troisième
point le périmètre temporel en réalité
dans dans le votre intervention
vous-même vous répondez à l'un des
griefs que vous semblez nous faire
puisque vous voyez bien que aucune
organisation syndicale n'est considérée
comme faisant partie des groupuscules
violents puisque vous l’indiquez
vous-même il y a nous nous prenons comme
date et ça a été un choix assumé par la
représentation nationale puisque ça a
été voté dans du cycle le fait que le
démarrage c'est le jour même du 49-3
donc
en réalité comment dire on est bien sur
le fait de dire que un certain nombre de
je dirais de d'évolution violente ont eu
lieu à partir de ce moment-là nous en
avons parfaitement conscience et c'est
surtout quelque chose qui a été débattu
dans notre hémicycle et en fait notre
commission d'enquête n'est que le
prolongement d'un vote effectué comme il
se doit je dirais au sein de de la
représentation nationale je ne serai pas
plus long sur sur ce point je laisse
monsieur le rapporteur complété puis
ensuite on vous repassera évidemment la
parole
oui merci monsieur le Président d'abord
merci à toutes et tous d'être présent ce
matin rapidement quelques éléments
d'éclairage il est assez rare en réalité
madame la secrétaire général que les
commissions d'enquête soient créées par
un vote de l'hémicycle c'est
relativement rare
il faut des éléments procédure rose tout
à fait spécifiques pour que la
commission d'enquête soit le principe
même de cette création et le périmètre
même de la commission d'enquête soit
votée par l'ensemble de l'hémicycle 47
voix contre de son 7 pour et c'est un
travail qui n'a pas été uniquement
l'émanation d'une ou de quelques
formations politiques pour ma part je
tiens à vous le rappeler pour le cas où
cette information vous aurez échappé
j'ai souhaité en particulier pas
simplement mais notamment que le terme
d'organisation des manifestations ne
figure pas dans l'intitulé il est
figurer dans une première version en
tant que rapporteur de la création de la
commission d'enquête à l'époque j'ai
souhaité que ce terme soit
très clairement pour qu'il n'y ait
aucune confusion possible avec les
organisateurs traditionnels des
manifestations que sont notamment les
organisations syndicales je reviens sur
ce que monsieur le Président vous a
indiqué si nous choisissons
collectivement dans l'hémicycle la date
du 16 mars c'est que nous avons
conscience d'un certain nombre de
phénomènes qui ont suivi l'usage du 49-3
c'est précisément parce que nous avons
conscience y compris quand on est député
de la majorité présidentielle comme moi
des de l'impact le soir même place de la
Concorde comme vous le savez de cette
décision d'usage du 43 que y compris les
députés de la majorité présidentielle
décident de faire partie et vous l'avez
très bien dit monsieur le secrétaire
général de Force Ouvrière de faire
partie
notre travail des premiers incidents car
toute la période d'amont donc or 49-3 se
passe très bien vous l'avez dit Monsieur
le Secrétaire général voilà nous avons
voté le 10 mai 81 c'est une date que
j'aime bien pour la création de cette
commission d'enquête pour ce qui me
concerne et il nous semble naturel je
réponds à votre première interrogation
d'interroger
les voix les plus fortes de vos
organisations pour une raison très
simple nous ne sommes pas une commission
technique et administrative nous sommes
là une commission d'enquête de
l'Assemblée nationale et lorsque nous
convoquons ce matin le ministre de la
Justice garde des sceaux nous ne qu'on
vous compare sont directement de cabinet
et lorsque nous convoquons le Préfecture
de Police de le préfet de police pardon
de Paris nous n'accepterions pas qu'il
soit représenté par son directeur de
cabinet ou son secrétaire général voilà
la raison pour laquelle nous sommes très
heureux de pouvoir vous écouter cet
après-midi
je trouve pas si évident à la parole
m'inscriture générale
je vous remercie
oui je voulais souligner que le passage
en force du 49-3 s'est accompagné d'une
hausse répressive condamnée par exemple
par la commissaire au droit de l'Homme
du Conseil de l'Europe qui s'est à
l'armée je cite d'un usage excessif de
la force en France que cette rapporteur
spéciaux des Nations Unies ont pointé un
jeu cite manque de retenue dans l'usage
de la force je cite toujours inquiétant
pour l'État de droit et appeler la
France à je cite un examen complet de
ces stratégies et pratiques en matière
de maintien de l'ordre le mouvement
syndical international notamment la
Confédération européenne des syndicats
et de nombreuses organisations
syndicales en France en Europe et dans
le monde ont dénoncé ces attaques contre
l'action syndicale en France et nous ont
apporté leur soutien l'interdiction de
nombreux rassemblements manifestations
et même diffusion de tracts par le
gouvernement en utilisant l'arsenal
antiterroriste a d'ailleurs été condamné
par les tribunaux qui ont annulé de
nombreuses décisions pour faire
respecter le droit de manifester
ce mouvement social inédit a aussi vu la
liberté d'expression menacée au travers
d'une grave répression qui s'était
battue sur les journalistes
puisque
reporters Sans Frontières s'est adressé
au ministre de l'Intérieur en ces termes
je cite les reporters couvrant les
rassemblements opposés à la réforme des
retraites on fait l'objet de nombreuses
interpellations arbitraires agressions
et intimidation de la part des forces de
l'ordre
la stratégie en matière de prévention
des violences a également été invalidée
par les tribunaux pendant les
manifestations de très nombreux
manifestants ou parfois de simples
passants ont été placés en garde à vue
avant d'être dans le écrasante majorité
relâcher 100 poursuite comme la
rapporter la presse certains gardaient à
vue ont même fait l'objet de fichage
alors qu'aucune poursuite n'a été
retenue contre eux par exemple en mai
dernier le tribunal administratif de
Lille a condamné l'État à verser une
somme de 3000 euros requérant pour avoir
créé un fichier recensant les garder à
vue lors de la mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites
enfin
certains militantes et militants
syndicaux notamment de la CGT ont été
convoqués placés en garde à vue et mis
en examen dans le cadre de leur activité
syndicale c'est notamment le cas de
Laurent indusiac secrétaire général de
l'udet de l'Allier donc de l'Union
départementale pardon de l'Allier membre
de la direction confédérale et hier de
Sébastien Ménesplier secrétaire
confédéral de la CGT secrétaire général
de la fédération de l'énergie qui a été
convoquée à la gendarmerie de
Montmorency le fait de traiter des
militants syndicaux de la sorte et de
tenter d'imputer au premier responsable
syndical d'un secteur professionnel par
ailleurs dirigeant national de la CGT un
acte décidé et organisé par les salariés
dans le cadre d'un mouvement social et
d'une grève appelée par les
organisations syndicales est une attaque
contre le syndicalisme
qui nous ramène aux heures sombres de
notre histoire sociale cette politique
répressive à l'égard des militantes et
militants syndicaux a même fait l'objet
d'une note officielle des services du
ministère du Travail faisant des
préconisations aux employeurs pour
entraver le droit de grève et pour
pouvoir notamment faciliter les
licenciements des élus du personnel
cette note a été révélée par le journal
l'Humanité donc son édition du 23 mars
2023 pour conclure je m'associerai à mes
homologues pour rappeler que les
libertés de manifester le droit de grève
et le droit syndical sont des libertés
constitutionnelles et que nous comptons
sur vous et sur l'Assemblée nationale
pour les faire respecter dans un
contexte où nous sommes extrêmement
préoccupés et inquiets par leur remise
en cause à tous les niveaux je lance
donc ici solennellement une alerte
démocratique sur cette question là
je m'arrêterai là sauf si vous voulez
que je réponde précisément
à d'autres questions merci beaucoup on
va continuer les interventions et puis
ensuite je laisserai évidemment aussi
monsieur le rapporteur posé un certain
nombre de questions donc je pense que
nous allons passer à la CFE-CGC donc je
suis engagé je vous passe la parole
merci monsieur le Président bonjour à
toutes et à tous
la CFE-CGC est un une organisation
syndicale qui d'ordinaire manifeste peu
nous sommes des novices en la matière
mais nous avons pris toute notre part
l'organisation en amont des
manifestations et des inter syndics en
inter syndical pendant et avec les
préfectures
nous disposons pas d'un service d'ordre
en tant que tel c'est-à-dire composé
d'un volant de militants choisi formé et
disponible nous souhaitons cependant
insister sur la reconnaissance que nous
avons envers nous autres organisations
syndicales
lesquels disposant de ce type de
ressources les ont en permanence mise à
disposition de l'ensemble des cortèges
et déclarés de tête
nous tenons à souligner le sang froid la
réactivité et la vigilance permanente
des membres de ses services d'ordre qui
ont permis à l'essentiel des
manifestations de se dérouler dans un
sentiment d'organisation maîtrisée de
sécurité
je voudrais rajouter à ces propos trois
points 1 1 2 satisfaction et de
vigilance le premier de satisfaction
étant le
fait d'avoir trouvé le parcours de
délestage qui a permis à tout le monde
de pouvoir manifester et bouger en même
temps et ne pas créer des îlots fixes
et les deux points de vigilance ce sont
les fins de manifestations qui sont pas
toujours
sécurisés au maximum notamment pour les
derniers arrivants et un point pour une
un ensemble d'organisations syndicales
qui sont pas présentes ici ou vendus ce
sont les lycéens et les étudiants qui
parlent leur jeunesse je dirais non pas
l'expérience et la vigilance et qu'il
faudrait peut-être leur donner un appui
un peu plus sécuritaire merci
je vous remercie parce que nous allons
passer à la CFTC donc monsieur Chabanier
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
députés c'est très bien mon collègue l'a
dit juste avant donc je pourrais faire
la même remarque nous sommes pas les
plus spécialistes des rassemblements des
manifestations
mais nous avons participé au 14
manifestations qui ont eu lieu et depuis
le départ c'est manifestations se sont
bien passés puisque ça a été très
souvent salué par notre qualité
d'organisation ça lui met aussi le côté
bon enfant de ces manifestations jusque
à la date du 16
ou évidemment il y a eu des conséquences
à certaines décisions vous avez parlé
vous-même monsieur le Président et ma
collègue Sophie Binet de du passage au
49.3 qui évidemment est les
organisations syndicales à des prévenus
depuis longtemps que ce type de mesure
elle est forcément augmenter la colère
même si évidemment nous dénonçons toutes
formes de violence et je tiens à le
redire très très fermement lutter contre
les violences évidemment une priorité
pour la CFTC on se sent toujours
concerné et les violences ne servent
jamais personne mais malheureusement
c'est souvent un marqueur quand le
dialogue est rompu et on ne peut que le
que le regretter
pour aller peut-être plus directement et
pas répéter ce que mes collègues ont dit
parce qu'évidemment on a beaucoup de
choses qu'on partage c'est peut-être pas
la peine de faire du du Reddit sur vos
sur vos questions que vous avez posé sur
ce que l'État correctement rempli son
devoir républicain en tout cas sur les
organisations de manifestation les
échanges qu'on a pu avoir avec la
préfecture sur la détermination des
cortèges des parcours sur l'organisation
ça s'est plutôt toujours bien passé
estime nous la fftc qui a pas eu de
problématique il y a ça et que donc les
les relations étaient plutôt bonnes
la relation avec l'autorité peut-être
l'autorité préfectorale même chose moi
je mettrai une une petite nuance mais
dans un dans une perspective
d'amélioration des choses il y a un
officier de liaison qui est déterminé et
qui est avec nous la plupart du temps
lors de ces manifestations et souvent en
relation d'ailleurs y compris avec le
cortège de tête ce n'est pas toujours la
même personne évidemment tout le monde a
droit à se reposer et on s'est rendu
compte d'une chose c'est que lorsque on
a un officier de liaison qui est présent
physiquement qui est très facilement
joignable souvent même à côté de nous
parmi nous on règle des tas de
difficultés qui viennent de manière
inopportune durant une manifestation il
y a eu quelques dates où l'officier de
liaison pour des raisons XY que je
dénonce personne c'est pas la question
n'était pas là physiquement ou c'était
difficile de joindre et là c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué parce qu'il se
passe toujours des choses inattendues
imprévisibles dans une manifestation
donc c'est simplement pour dire il y a
encore une fois n'allait pas chercher ce
qui était présent ou pas c'est pas le
but de mon intervention mais pour dire
que cette personne là les capitales elle
est essentielle et quand elle est là
présent y compris physiquement on évite
beaucoup de choses
la deuxième chose c'est on s'occupe des
des manifestations et donc de la
sécurité des manifestations de la tête
du cortège à la fin du cortège des
manifestants donc nous évidemment ce qui
se passe pré-corpège au milieu ou au
point d'arrivée
on ne le maîtrise pas mes collègues
l'ont dit mon collègue de la CGC faisait
remarquer la problématique du de la
place d'arrivée moi je ferai une
remarque on a extrêmement contrôlé
extrêmement difficile pour nos militants
qui portent nos chasus ben nos drapeaux
de nos organisations de se rendre au
point de rassemblement où il y a par
définition zéro problème parce que les
violences ne commencent jamais à l'heure
du début de la manifestation c'est
beaucoup plus simple de se rendre en
cours de parcours ou à l'arrivée du
parcours même avant des fois qu'on soit
qu'on ait démarré la manifestation donc
ça ça peut poser question dans toujours
dans une volonté de pouvoir améliorer
les choses et quant auprès cortège nous
avec la CFTC on a zéro relation avec les
pré-corpages vous allez poser la
question on les connaît pas j'ai pas de
contact pas de relation je suis pas sûr
de vouloir en avoir d'ailleurs merci
je vous remercie donc comme je vous l'ai
indiqué je vais passer la parole à
Monsieur le rapporteur pour qu'il puisse
poser ces questions et donc les
collègues qui tout à l'heure
souhaiteront intervenir merci de vous
manifester
oui merci Monsieur le
le Président Madame Binet secrétaire
général vous avez parlé de grave
répression à l'encontre des journalistes
en particulier je vous invite à
regarder la vidéo le replay des
représentants un certain nombre de
médias en particulier pas que les
chaînes d'information continue qui nous
ont fait part de leur expérience de
terrain à l'occasion d'attendre de
rassemblement ou de manifestations je
vous assure que la cible qui était la
leur n'était pas les forces de l'ordre
en revanche nous avons effectivement
pointé me semble-t-il je parle sous
contrôle pluraliste de mes collègues une
difficulté sur une autre catégorie de
journalistes qui sont les journalistes
de rue où là il y a sans doute des
évolutions d'identification en
particulier parfois même de formation
de lien avec les forces de l'ordre
d'attention aussi des forces de l'ordre
elle-même
mais il me semble que sur la relation
journaliste vous propose sont allés en
tout cas au delà des constats que nous
avons pu faire à travers notre travail
de parlementaire dans le cadre de cette
commission d'enquête et vous pourrez
peut-être apporter un éclairage
supplémentaire
au fond ce qui nous intéresse on vous
auditionnant
c'est de comprendre dans quelle séquence
on se situe
il semblerait quand même qu'il y ait un
constat partagé de ce que il est un
certain nombre d'individus
dans toute la question est de savoir
s'ils sont organisés s'ils sont
structurés s'ils sont coordonnés qui
mettent à profit un stand de
rassemblement tout à fait légitime
pour décryper décupler la violence
parfois d'ailleurs en contrariété même
avec les objectifs des manifestants
eux-mêmes et même toujours dès lors que
il y a violence et vous l'avez dit ce
que ce que ta génération des forces
ouvrières c'est même un message violence
qui vient parasiter le vôtre me
semble-t-il nous sommes tous d'accord
là-dessus ce qui nous intéresse c'est de
comprendre comment ces violences
s'organisent
qui les coordonnent est-ce que l'on a
des profils particuliers
comment nous pouvons mieux lutter contre
ces phénomènes avec toutes les
institutions et vous faites partie des
institutions en tant qu'organisation
syndicale voilà notre notre objectif
lorsque nous sommes hier à Sainte Soline
avec un centre de collègues présents
nous aurons l'occasion chers collègues
de vous faire une restitution précise de
nos constats hier il apparaît par
exemple une chose qui n'est pas
forcément applicable aux manifestations
urbaines
même quand elles sont interdites comme
Hassan Soline
pour qu'il y a affrontement il faut
qu'il y ait volonté contact quand on est
à Sainte-Souline et pour qu'il y ait
volonté de contact c'est très concret
très physique il faut plusieurs
centaines de mètres
parcourus là où les forces de l'ordre
elles sont statiques
là nous faisons des constats objectifs
donc voilà ce qui nous intéresse c'est
votre regard
sur ces situations qui se multiplient
idéal les phénomènes le cas échéant
déclencheur et nous n'ignorons rien des
conséquences de l'article en 93 la date
je l'ai déjà dit
cours à ce moment-là mais enfin le 49-3
n'explique pas les blocs
les 49-3 le corps de froide explique pas
des personnes qui sont venues pour en
découdre et qui parasitent encore une
fois même des formes trahissent un
certain nombre de messages de
contestations de revendications qui sont
les votes moi je suis très attaché à ce
qu'on puisse réfléchir ensemble
là-dessus j'entends les voilà stratégies
de la violence de la part de l'État
attaque contre le syndicalisme
répression du mouvement syndical pardon
c'est pas d'ailleurs si ces propos sont
partagés partout et toutes mais ce qui
nous intéresse c'est ce phénomène
extrêmement grave
qui d'un côté déstabilisent très
fortement nos forces de l'ordre qui ont
grande difficulté pour y faire face et
il y a des interrogations stratégiques
de la part de l'État
idemment des revendications de la part
des forces de l'ordre de moyens
supplémentaires est-ce que c'est une
bonne chose je ne sais pas en tant que
rapporteur j'essaierai de proposer des
des éléments et puis il y a à la fois
des organisations politiques des
organisations syndicales qui ont le
sentiment je pense que ça n'est pas
qu'un sentiment d'être au fond dépassé
par cette violence débordée par cette
violence ça c'est un phénomène je ne
sais pas si des sociologiques je ne sais
pas si les politiques je ne sais pas si
les sociaux politiques en tout cas il
est là et nous on essaie de comprendre
et aujourd'hui le but c'est d'essayer de
comprendre avec vous donc sur cet
élément de l'apparition déclenchement de
la violence quel est votre analyse
on peut parler aussi des responsabilités
bien sûr mais quel est votre analyse je
pense que ça c'est important pour nous
merci beaucoup sur l'apporteur donc je
fais pas qui parmi vous souhaite
monsieur Souillot je vous en prie
alors le phénomène n'est pas nouveau
si on regarde les manifestations et si
on prend 1968 par exemple il y avait
déjà tout un tas de violence
en 1986 c'était la même chose
2016 sur la loi travail et vous l'avez
rappelé tout à l'heure monsieur le
président
il y a toujours eu
des échauffourés et des choses comme ça
ce qui peut-être aujourd'hui
permet
plus d'organisation de ces groupes dont
je ne suis pas certain qu'il soit
organisé
réseaux sociaux comment on se retrouve
ici ou là
pour nous organisations syndicale on n'a
pas de de lien direct même nos
responsables de services d'ordre
deux ou trois ici quatre ou cinq là et à
chaque fois
on préserve nous le caractère c'est
comme ça que je vous expliquais la corde
cette corde qui de temps en temps peut
aussi nous peut nous poser problème
quand
nous sommes coincés entre les forces de
l'ordre le pré-corpège et nous
parce que là on recule mais on recule
organisé donc
je sais pas comment ils sont organisent
alors tout le monde les appelle les
blocs les Black Blocs ou je ne sais pas
quoi mais c'est un petit peu ce que
disait à de mes camarades tout à l'heure
quand nous on doit arriver pour aller
dans le cortège depuis 2016 c'est devenu
une norme que nous continuons de
contester y compris auprès du Prophète
police de Paris
on passe pas à la fouille mais quasiment
et parfois y compris avec
le support de notre drapeau pour aller
manifester ou les gendarmes mobiles et
CRS nous disent ben non ça vous pouvez
pas l'emmener donc il y a tout un tas de
contrôle pour nos manifestants qui
arrivent
et après
pour
pour nous c'était une des questions que
vous posiez
est-ce qu'il y a des représentants
syndicaux qui ont été victimes et tout
cela
on a eu un militant il faut RATP qui a
été blessé le 7 mars et donc on est
avant
après une agression par des membres d'un
bloc dont on sait pas dire si c'est
comment elle s'est constituée ou pas ou
si c'était juste sa tête qui ne leur
venait pas ou si comme il était
estampillé RATP comme il y avait grève
dans le métro il n'avait pas pu prendre
le métro c'est pas
c'est pas quelque chose d'organiser et
dans tous les cas nous responsables de
services d'ordre quand le pré-corpège se
rapproche trop près de nous ben nous on
ralentit
ce que vous expliquiez sur Sainte Soline
et là c'est pas la même chose et je veux
pas entrer dans ce débat
mais nous on est pas statique
notre manifestation elle se déplace et
quand on fait le dépôt
on dit de quel endroit on part et à quel
endroit on arrive entre deux c'est vrai
que les itinéraires de délestage qui ont
été mises en place c'est parce qu'il y
avait
des manifestants comme nous n'avions pas
vu depuis très longtemps à Paris il
fallait que tout le monde puisse
manifester donc là la liberté de
manifester avec l'itinéraire de
détestage a bien été tenu et entretenu
mais sur le reste
des échauffourés ou des violences
il y en a toujours eu autour des
manifestations maintenant est-ce que
c'est l'évolution de la communication
qui permet à certains de s'organiser je
ne sais pas le dire
je vous remercie qui d'autre oui je vous
en prie madame
merci beaucoup j'ai compléterai les
propos de Frédéric Souillot puisque je
suis relativement enfin très en phase je
ne répondrai pas la question concernant
sainte-sol puisque c'est un événement
sur lesquels mon organisation n'a pas de
n'a pas eu de lien ni d'implication
c'est une question redoutable les
éléments déclencheurs je pense qu'ils
sont multiples et que c'est extrêmement
compliqué de savoir pourquoi un moment
la violence croit et pourquoi des
personnes organisées ou pas je ne sais
pas
dessine de de monter en puissance en
termes de d'action
et moi je ne ferai que le témoignage
donc est-ce que le 16 a été un moment de
bascule pour mon organisation nous n'en
sommes pas convaincus il y a eu un
recours le recours au cas au 49-3 mais
je dirais que c'est
probablement un multifactoriel il y a
également eu un mouvement un mouvement
majeur une journée record le 7 mars
juste avant avec des propositions que
l'Inter syndicale avait faite de main
tendue vers le gouvernement disons
parlons-nous vont des discussions
une médiation a même été proposée et
quand l'ensemble des man protestants ont
pour seule réponse pas de son pas
d'image de qui que ce soit et pour il a
été évoqué le syndicalisme européen on a
on échange régulièrement avec nos
responsables la Confédération européenne
des syndicats il nous a appelé en disant
bon vous avez eu vous avez bien eu
quelqu'un du gouvernement vous avez eu
ou le président a défaut du président de
la République quelqu'un de du ministère
du Travail ou et quand on leur disait
pas de son pas d'image eux-mêmes étaient
totalement stupéfait donc voilà je pense
qu'il y a un ensemble de d'éléments et
moi je me garderai bien de de faire une
réponse définitive sur ces éléments
déclencheurs
ce qui est certain et je reprendrai les
termes d'une militante de Lyon alors je
ne sais plus à quelle date parce qu'il y
en a eu beaucoup qui qui avait été ou
une fin de manifestation avec du je
crois être anticipé
elle nous avait dit mais c'est ces
personnes nous confisquent notre message
est confisque nos donc la question nous
n'avons aucune relation avec ces
personnes
nous partageons le fait que leurs
actions elles sont pas parfois elles
vont pas parfois à l'encontre de ce que
l'on porte elles vont toujours à
l'encontre lorsqu'on défend une
manifestation dans un cadre pacifique et
donc de non-violence ça c'est tout
toujours contre-productif c'est toujours
contre-productif et et nombre de
militants ce sont souvent désolés que le
soir d'une belle manifestation
avec des cortèges
festifs ou beaucoup de participants
faisaient leur première manifestation
parce que c'est un sujet sur le travail
qui leur tenait à cœur et qui leur tient
toujours à cœur
nombreux sont sont ces
se manifestants à dire les voilà le le
comment dire les les messages que l'on
porte ils doivent pas se faire
confisquer par des images de personnes
qui vont casser un McDo si je fais de la
pub il faut que je dise d'autres noms de
De
Flunch si tu veux mais
bref de banque voilà donc ça ça fait
vraiment partie aussi de notre notre
vision de l'organisation de ces
manifestations
est-ce que les organisations sont
dépassées là je renverrai je renverrai
la question à est-ce que les forces de
l'ordre sont dépassées parce que je
rappelle que notre périmètre d'action
c'est l'organisation de la sécurité des
cortèges et ce qui nous ce qui est de
notre responsabilité c'est que ces
personnes ne pénètrent pas le cortège
elles peuvent faire des tentatives
parfois les il peut y avoir des la zone
ou des moments de la manifestation ou
c'est plus facile de d'essayer de d'y
pénétrer mais voilà pour avoir été 14
fois dans le caractère pour la CFDT
voilà ça fait partie des choses qui
étaient que j'ai pu moi-même constater
physiquement et que et que du coup les
la question du du développement de ces
structures organes plus ou moins
organisées
elles elles ont elles ont pour objectif
de
faire passer un autre message par la
violence et et je pense que c'est aussi
enfin c'est d'abord une question de qui
concerne les forces de l'ordre après
nous on est en relation avec elle et on
le fait en bonne intelligence je pense
qu'on en a tous on en a tous témoigné
ou globalement voilà les choses se sont
passées de façon
positive
je vous remercie
madame Binet peut-être je m'inscris dans
le dans le prolongement d'abord sur la
question de l'augmentation du phénomène
bon il faut toujours faire attention aux
raccourcis historiques nous aussi
d'ailleurs en attendant ça les faire
mais quand on regarde l'histoire sur une
période longue on voit que la violence
elle est très relative évidemment si on
compare avec ce qui s'est passé en mai
68 dans les manifs pendant la
décolonisation etc il y avait des
violences de part et d'autre qui étaient
d'un niveau autre que celui qu'on a pu
constater et donc là dessus moi je pense
que c'est pas nous qui pouvons qui
sommes d'ailleurs les mieux outillés
pour vous répondre c'est plutôt des
sociologues ou des historiens qui
peuvent apporter des réponses factuelles
sur l'analyse du pourquoi pareil c'est
compliqué mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
quand il y a une violence qui est
commise en nombre et donc pas seulement
par un individu tout seul il y a
toujours une grande colère derrière
c'était quand même ça le point commun et
cette colère elle est elle a été
caractéristiques là dans le la
mobilisation par le fait comme l'a dit
Marylise que les organisations
syndicales à de multiples reprises dès
le début de la mobilisation nous n'avons
cessé avant chaque jour de mobilisation
après chaque jour de mobilisation de
tendre la main au pouvoir et d'ouvrir
des portes de sortie de plein de façons
différentes on a demandé au président de
la République de nous recevoir il ne
nous a pas reçu on a demandé au
président de la République d'organiser
un référendum il ne l'a pas fait on a
demandé au président de la République de
refaire voter le Parlement après la
censure du Conseil constitutionnel il ne
l'a pas fait bref on a eu beaucoup
d'imagination pour tendre des mains en
permanence mains qui n'ont jamais été
saisies et donc forcément ça a fait
monter le la colère et ça ce qui est sûr
c'est que c'est un terreau fertile ça
c'est l'évidence et donc c'est pour ça
qu'il y a toujours une dimension
politique plus générale que la seule
stratégie du maintien de l'ordre
sur la question du cortège de tête donc
comme mes homologues nous n'avons aucune
relation avec le cortège de tête qui
d'ailleurs en général est plusieurs
enfin 100 200 300 mètres devant il est
vraiment loin de nous
il y a pas dans cette mobilisation comme
dans les autres de
d'éléments violents qui sont rentrés
dans les cortèges des organisations
syndicales on n'a pas eu ce problème là
et d'ailleurs dans cette mobilisation on
n'a pas eu nous à être victime de
violence les seuls incidents dont nous
avons été victimes elle était plutôt de
du fait des forces de l'ordre le 7
février à Paris où il y a une charge de
police sur le service d'ordre le 11 mars
et le 23 mars ou le carré de tête a été
gazé voilà
sur les comment est-ce que les choses
pourraient être améliorées moi j'ai
quelques remarques factuelles après pour
avoir des choses plus précises encore
une fois ce serait mieux de d'interroger
celles et ceux qui sont en charge
directement de cette responsabilité la
première sur les questions de
circulation
de plus en plus on se retrouve aussi à
devoir gérer le la coupure de la
circulation enfin donc à empêcher la
circulation des voitures donc ça ça nous
rajoute une tâche qui normalement n'est
pas de notre ressort la deuxième c'est
quand même une remarque générale c'est
que moins les forces de l'ordre sont
visibles moins il y a d'incident il y a
aussi une question de quand il y a un
niveau de tension dans le pays le fait
d'avoir des forces de l'ordre qui sont
en grand nombre et très visibles ça
c'est vécu ça peut être vécu comme une
provocation et puis la dernière chose
d'ailleurs c'est une question que vous
nous posiez précisément
c'est que sur la question de c'était
votre question 12 je crois sur
les
ingérences dans nos cortèges donc ça
c'est un point d'alerte ferme c'est à
dire que il faut absolument pas qu'il y
ait d'ingérence dans nos cortèges
syndicaux et là en l'occurrence les
forces qui maintenant sont en charge de
faire ça c'est la bravème et donc à
chaque fois c'est vécu comme une
provocation une violence de la part des
militants qui défilent dans nos cortèges
pacifiquement donc ça c'est vraiment un
point d'alerte
et je rejoins tout à fait ce qu'a dit
Marylise Léon sur le fait que on n'est
pas dépassé enfin il y a pas de problème
d'organisation syndicale qui sont
dépassés puisque nos cortèges encore une
fois de A à Z ont toujours été
pacifiques et bien organisé
je vous remercie monsieur Tanguay oui je
vous en prie c'est Monsieur temps je me
sépare pardon c'est d'origine
non je voulais juste rajouter que on a
vécu justement ce contraste entre la
bonne entente le bon ambiance qui avait
dans les dans les cortèges syndicaux et
un mouvement qu'on apprécie devant nous
quelques centaines de mètres de vent
faut reconnaître l'action des forces de
l'ordre qui a fait que en gérant la
distance entre le carré de tête et c'est
mieux
moi j'appelle ça des casseurs excusez
moi mais parce que quand on passait
derrière on voyait bien ce qui s'était
passé quelques centaines de mètres
devant nous et ce qu'on constatait c'est
des magasins cassés des abribus des
enfin rien à voir avec un discours
syndical ni une revendication
c'est la plus violence et si
effectivement il y a eu cette évolution
c'est que manifestants 14 fois je
comprends que certains puissent prendre
goût au fait que on puisse casser
délibérément sans sans devoir recourir
grand chose quand on est bien cagoulé
masqué qu'on a reconnu par personne et
dans un effet de groupe puisqu'on voyait
bien que c'était les groupes qui
bougeaient très mobiles
voilà donc nous de notre point de vue on
a été accompagné par ses forces de l'an
parce qu'on a vu qu'il y a une action
qui a été faite et en aucun cas on a été
soumis à cette tension ou à cette
violence donc ça on peut les en
remercier effectivement le je sais plus
11 mars on a un retour de gaz
lacrymogène parce que le groupe était
trop près de nous pour pour éviter ça
puis malheureusement les éléments
naturels comme le vent ne sont pas
dominés par les forces de l'ordre et
mais dans l'ensemble on a aucun de nos
manifestants et on a eu des
manifestations à samedi là où on a eu
aussi des familles des parents qui sont
venus et avec les pour lesquels c'était
une manifestation de très grandes joies
et de d'engouement on va pas remercier
Monsieur Macron de nous avoir fait
défilé aussi souvent mais on a créé des
moments qui pour nous étaient un peu
réjouissants parce que de voir que ce
CGC ça veut se mobiliser même en
manifestant c'était une nouveauté pour
nous donc voilà non donc chacun son rôle
malheureusement on peut pas vous
indiquer de quelle violence il s'agit
parce que c'est pas notre rôle nous
notre rôle c'est déjà de d'accompagner
nos groupes et de les préserver chose
qui on n'a pas dû faire puisqu'ils
étaient dans un espace sécurisé après
qui sont on a aucun contact avec eux on
les connaît pas on voit des mouvements
c'est tout merci je vous remercie
monsieur tanze donc je passe la parole à
Monsieur Chabanier
oui pour le parler de groupuscule
organisé ou pas c'est très très
compliqué pour nous de répondre à cette
question puisqu'on les connaît pas les
fréquentes pas mais j'allais vous dire
que c'est même pas une question de
d'organisation aujourd'hui même des
mouvements qui ne sont pas organisés
sont capables de s'organiser en 5
minutes grâce au réseau sociaux donc les
mouvements non organisés ont la capacité
à s'organiser en 5 minutes aujourd'hui
donc à la limite la question se pose
même plus si ces mouvements qui est très
organisé ou pas les réseaux les
connexions font qu'on s'organise en cinq
minutes vous parliez des des
manifestations spontanées dont nous en
l'occurrence on a pas participé à
validation aux manifestations spontanées
parce qu'on sait que c'est encore un
risque de violence souvent plus accrue
parce que là en l'occurrence il y a
aucun service d'ordre de des
organisations syndicales au moins dans
des manifestations qui sont déclarées en
encadrement du carithète jusqu'au bout
de notre manifestation même si on
encadre pas nos collègues lundi tout ce
qui est devant tout ce qui se passe
devant mais dans des manifestations qui
sont spontanées on y participe pas on
n'a jamais appelé à y être et on y était
pas je pense je peux pas vous dire que
aucun de mes 150 000 militants y étaient
pas mais en tout cas on n'a jamais
appelé à y être donc je ne sais pas
comment ça marche moi je redis pour
notre organisation qui il faut il y a
peut-être deux trois choses qui sont qui
sont perfectibles le
la première chose et je crois que c'est
Frédéric Souillot qu'il a dit tout à
l'heure quand on a quand il y a des
forces de l'ordre en nombre très
conséquent qui passent des longues
minutes voire des heures à fouiller des
militants qui sont complètement habillés
en CGT en CFDT ou en CFTC c'est c'est
pas celui-là qui va les casser il est
identifié à mort s'il fallait que cours
d'ailleurs avec un portant le drapeau
des trucs ça serait compliqué pour qu'il
s'échappe donc c'est pas un casseur donc
je vais peut-être mieux sécuriser
les routes on va dire qui sont qui sont
en parallèle au moment du cortège nous
la chose qui nous a marqué à la CFTC et
nos services de sécurité l'ont dit alors
je suis comme mes collègues c'est-à-dire
j'ai pas répondu à la question mais j'ai
pas des professionnels de la sécurité
même si évidemment nos syndicats qui
travaillent dans la sécurité leur
demande en premier lieu s'il veut bien
au fil un coup de main parce qu'ils ont
quelques expériences mais ce qui nous
marque c'est c'est le l'afflux de
personnes sur le lieu d'arriver alors
que le cortège il est pas encore parti
c'est-à-dire on de République on est en
train de se mobiliser à République il y
a des fouilles de de fou pour arriver
jusqu'à République les métros sont
fermés les gens qui sont entièrement
habillés CFTC CFDT CGT et fausses que
vous voulez s'en fouiller à mort il y a
des centaines de personnes qui affluent
sur le point d'arriver à nations qui
arrivent tranquillement qui sont
quasiment pas fouillées et quand le
cortège après arrive au moment de la fin
mais forcément ça se passe ça se passe
mal puisqu'on a laissé s'affluer un tas
de monde et c'est là qu'il faudrait
peut-être un petit peu faire faire des
choses voilà bon et après il y a une
chose que je voulais terminer c'est
c'est le problème mais je veux
évidemment réduire aucun droit de
liberté la presse ou quoi que ce soit
mais
le jour où on a arrêté de compter les
voitures brûlées à Strasbourg pour la
Saint Sylvestre comme par hasard il y a
deux fois moins ou trois fois moins de
voitures qui ont brûlé donc le jour où
on arrêtera de mettre les violences du
matériau au soir en avant et ne plus
parler du de la manifestation tout à
l'heure tout le monde disait vous disiez
que ça jouait contre nous parce qu'on
oublie les revendications on oublie nos
combats et on se focalise sur les
violences peut-être que
alors c'est une impression personnelle
mais j'ai l'impression que plus on
montre les gens violents passer à la
télé ou plus ils ont envie d'y passer
donc je me permettrai cette dernière
remarque personnelle
je vous remercie monsieur taverne je
vous en prie
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et Messieurs les
représentants des organisations
syndicales
donc déjà moi ce que je retiens c'est
que Monsieur le Secrétaire général de la
Force Ouvrière a bien rappelé qu'il y
avait eu depuis 19 ans janvier 12
manifestations ce qui sont très bien
déroulés et il y a eu des bons échanges
des bons rapports avec les forces de
l'ordre autrement grâce aux équipes de
liaison et d'informations
et ensuite je voudrais rappeler que
l'État de droit est respecté dans notre
pays grâce aux forces de l'ordre
s'il n'y avait pas de force de l'ordre
vous ne pourriez pas manifester de cette
façon là
j'entends des personnels politiques
certaines organisations syndicales je ne
mets pas tout le monde en panier qui
nous parle des pays étrangers allez voir
dans les pays étrangers comment ça se
passe et ensuite vous reviendrez en
France et vous expirez exactement ce que
vous avez vu à l'étranger en France on a
cette honneur justement de pouvoir
gagner de la meilleure façon possible
les manifestations qui est un droit
constitutionnel et qui doit être
parfaitement respecté
j'entends parler de de répression madame
madame Binet de quelle répression
parlez-vous
exactement
puisqu'effectivement nous avons
auditionné comme l'a dit monsieur le
rapporteur nous avons auditionné les les
principaux médias et et non pas
spécialement vu de violence de la part
de de force de l'ordre notamment puisque
il y a cette petite musique qu'on
connaît de la part de de la CGT donc
ensuite
connaissez-vous exactement le cadre
légal du maintien de l'ordre vous savez
que il y a des individus qui viennent
pour perturber
les manifestations qui effacent le
message que vous voulez transmettre qui
est parfaitement légitime et ces
individus là sont sont
organisés pour déstructurer les
manifestations et provoquer le chaos et
les forces de l'ordre sont là justement
pour éviter le chaos et la plupart des
manifestations se sont parfaitement bien
déroulées
donc il y a également les organisations
qui commettent plusieurs violences donc
j'aimerais bien vous entendre là-dessus
et quand vous parlez des braves m vous
ne parlez pas de revendications sociales
vous parlez comme la France insoumise
vous parlez vous faites passer un
message politique donc quel est votre
votre but c'est de faire de la politique
ou alors de faire passer un message
on va dire social
donc là dessus j'aimerais bien vous vous
entendre pour avoir la distinction entre
les manifestations et les forces de
l'ordre notamment peut-être c'est
violences policières que que vous
critiquez systématiquement merci
qui parmi vous souhaite s'exprimer
[Musique]
non pas de pas de réaction particulière
monsieur je vous en prie
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et Messieurs les
responsables syndicaux
je suis assez Farré d'entendre
vos témoignages les uns les autres et
d'entendre surtout une sorte de
passivité
d'attentisme voire d'aveuglement par
rapport aux violences qui émaillent et
qui pourrissent vos manifestations
depuis un certain nombre d'années ça
fait quand même depuis 2016 au moins où
on insiste un pourrissement de quasiment
toutes les manifestations sociales par
les mêmes groupuscules avec les mêmes
modes opératoires et j'ai l'impression
qu'à vous entende ça ne vous concerne
pas on ne connaît pas on ne sait pas si
c'est organisé on n'a pas voulu
rechercher etc mais moi je tiens à vous
dire que vous êtes concerné et nous
sommes tous concernés et vous avez une
responsabilité majeure écrasante parce
qu'effectivement ces groupuscules
viennent totalement dénaturer des causes
qui sont totalement légitime par exemple
l'opposition à la réforme des retraites
il y a des messages aussi je vous le dis
qu'on peut pas entendre ce ne sont pas
Madame Binet les forces de l'ordre qui
sont responsables de la violence jamais
en France jamais et j'aimerais et on
souhaiterait que vous puissiez apporter
aussi un peu de soutien quelques
secondes de soutien aux forces de
l'ordre à tous ces policiers à tous ces
gendarmes qui ont été tabassés qui ont
été blessés grièvement blessés dans ces
manifestations jamais un mot pour les
forces de l'ordre alors on sait très
bien que demain vous allez aller à Niort
pour soutenir les éco-terroristes donc
de sainte Soline on aimerait aussi que
vous alliez au chevet des policiers
blessés que vous alliez peut-être devant
le ministère de l'Intérieur pour
réaffirmer votre soutien la police
nationale les républicaines qui
effectivement comme l'a dit mon collègue
taverne vous permet de manifester dans
la paix et puis monsieur Chabanier
excusez-moi mais le fait de d'occulter
la réalité
ne va pas rendre les Black Blocs
pacifiques le fait de cacher ce qui se
passe comme vous l'avez dit il faudrait
pas on a cessé de compter les voitures
brûlées donc il y a moins de voitures
brûlées ça tout c'est un faux débat et
je pense que ne pas vouloir voir le
problème ne pas vouloir voir que c'est
manifestations sont de plus en plus
soumises à la violence c'est assez grave
et au contraire il faut en parler pour
en comprendre les causes et c'est le
rôle et en tout cas la fonction de cette
commission d'enquête je vous remercie
merci chers collègues qui parmi vous
souhaite prendre la parole
oui monsieur Germany je vous en prie
je veux dire deux petits mots rapidement
parce que j'ai été nommé
premièrement il semble il me semble pas
que j'ai dit que les violences
concernaient personne vous regarderez le
replay ce que je sais que ça passe en
replay ma première phrase de mon
intervention était je vais la lire
doucement pour que tout le monde
comprenne et entendent ce que l'écoute
est importante dans ce genre de
commission la lutte contre les violences
sous toutes leurs formes doit tous nous
concerner la violence de Sers personne
première phrase que j'ai dit dans mon
intervention donc je pense que c'est pas
un bon procès que vous faites
deuxième chose
j'ai jamais dit qu'il fallait se cacher
la face et pas regarder ça
je dis que faire de la publicité au
casseurs encourage encore les casseurs à
venir plus nombreux et plus le faire
faire la publicité ça ne veut pas dire
ne pas s'intéresser au sujet et la
première phrase montrer bien qu'on
s'intéresse au sujet je pense que la
publicité incite dire que la publicité
incite veut pas dire qu'on ne veut pas
en parler ou qu'on se voit la face ou
qu'on ne veut pas regarder enfin je
crois pas ou alors je m'exprime
peut-être pas pas très bien mais c'est
pas la même chose ensuite quand je dis
que je ne connais pas les casseurs
j'espère quand même que tous les
Français que monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur vous-même être
plutôt content que je ne connaisse pas
les casseurs ça veut dire que je suis
pas parmi eux que je participe pas et
que je ne fais pas ça donc quand je dis
que à la question avez-vous des liens
avez-vous des connaissances une question
précise que monsieur le président m'a
posé j'ai essayé de répondre à cette
question très précise je reprends la
question parce que peut-être que là
aussi je me suis trompé où j'ai souvent
des problèmes d'écoute mes collègues
pourront vous le vous le confirmer ça
m'arrive souvent mais
on était vraiment sûr ça sur donc moi je
dis non on a avec les pré cortèges
questions du président donc j'ai pas de
relation je les connais pas je les
fréquente pas et ça devrait plutôt faire
plaisir à tout le monde comme fréquente
pas ces casseurs quoi voilà donc je vous
dis simplement la vérité après je mets
les groupes muscules et qu'est-ce que
comment voulez-vous qu'on sache ces
groupuscules sont organisés par
organisés j'ai simplement eu la
sincérité de dire que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui avec les réseaux sociaux
que vous soyez bien ou pas organisé vous
pouvez vous organiser en 5 minutes c'est
un c'est une réalité qu'il faut
surmonter ça me paraît être juste une
réalité
voilà et et
on
une organisation syndicale organise une
une manifestation on vous l'a dit on
protège une manifestation on a
rendez-vous nous les leaders dans le
carré de tête qui est généralement quand
on se réunit à République nos militants
sont à République et nous nous sommes de
300 mètres pour démarrer le cortège
avant dans une avenue comment
voulez-vous qu'on voit qu'on regarde ce
qui se passe 800 mètres 1 km avant la
plupart des dégradations des cases et
des choses se passent un kilomètre 800
mètres avant
c'est pas qu'on s'y intéresse pas ou
c'est pas qu'on le voit pas
quand je suis à République je suis pas
nation quoi quand je suis faim tout
simplement qu'est-ce que vous voulez
qu'on fasse sur ça et la sécurité
publique c'est pas notor enfin je veux
dire c'est pas notre responsabilité
voilà c'est simplement c'est pas on
essaie de faire le maximum pour protéger
nos cortèges qui se sont plutôt bien
passé avec des gens qui sont pas des
professionnels qui sont des militants
volontaires qui parfois prennent des
coups des militants volontaires mais
c'est quand vous marchez qu'au bout d'un
moment vous voyez au loin de la fumée
parce qu'une poubelle brûle vous
apercevez à peine au loin qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que je vous réponde sur ça
et que je vous dis sur ça donc je trouve
vraiment que ce voilà les procès sur on
s'en fout on regarde pas un truc comme
ça je crois vraiment pas que c'était mon
discours j'aimerais que certains
écoutent mon replay pour bien se rendre
compte de ce que j'ai dit
je vous remercie je passe la parole à
Monsieur le rapporteur et puis ensuite
monsieur Lucas c'était également
manifesté je vous la passerai donc après
le éventuellement un échange avec les
représentants syndicaux
merci monsieur le Président où je
laisserai notre collègue Lucas poser la
dernière question avec tempérance avec
le sens de de rassemblement de nos
travaux mon cher Benjamin de remarques
la première quand je parle de
dépassement
organisation syndicale dépassée le terme
peut-être pas effectivement approprié je
je veux dire par là que le fait que les
précortèges grossissent
sont aussi la démonstration me
semble-t-il en tout cas c'est ce qui
ressort des auditions et des réflexions
qui sont les nôtres au cours des
derniers mois une forme sinon de
contestation en tout cas
de réserve ou de distance à la gare à
l'égard pardon de tout ce qui est
organisation représentative quelle
qu'elle soit une certaine façon et donc
nous avons le sentiment mais je
travaille peut-être des pensées qui ne
sont pas collectives mais le sentiment
que il y a là une forme de de oui de
dépassement au sens où des formations
politiques des organisations syndicales
font certains nos concitoyens se
retrouvent pas dans leur mode d'action
et donc décident par exemple de se
mettre en dehors des cari de tête en
dehors de la manifestation organisée
avec la corde comme vous disiez il y a
quelques instants c'était le sens de ma
remarque je ne sais pas si vous avez en
retour des observations à me communiquer
un point très concret il apparaît dans
nos auditions que le moment de la
dispersion est un moment clé j'entends
les remarques qui ont été faites sur le
contrôle du lieu d'arrivée ou des accès
latéraux et ça on en tiendra compte dans
le dans le rapport mais la question de
la dispersion semble toujours sont très
stratégique et on voit aussi que du côté
de l'État
il y a des interrogations j'imagine que
vous les connaissez et qu'elles sont
partagées en tout cas je le souhaiterais
qu'elle le soit avec vous c'est-à-dire
comment mieux communiquer sur le temps
de dispersion comment faire en sorte que
les manifestants soient le mieux informé
possible de la situation à mon
de façon à ce qu'il y ait vraiment des
capacités pour chacun de réagir comme il
le convient les forces de l'ordre de
s'attaquer aux affrontements qu'ils
subissent vous-même de protéger la
manifestation et vos propres
manifestants sur la question de la
dispersion est-ce qu'il y a des
préconisations
qui seraient intéressante de reprendre
dans le rapport on nous a parlé de
communication de meilleure visibilité de
de messages sonores à l'image d'ailleurs
de ce qui peut se faire dans certains
États de l'Union européenne qui n'est
manifestement pas pratiqué de façon
performante en tout cas
au niveau français
merci Monsieur rapporteur mesdames
messieurs parmi vous quelqu’un souhaite
se réagir ces interrogations notion de
rapporteur oui madame Léon je vous en
prie
de deux éléments
il y avait une question
relative au dernier point je garde le
meilleur pour la fin sur la question
des précortèges qui grossit ou qui
grossiraient je pense que la question se
pose néanmoins sur la question des des
fins de cortège effectivement
on a la dispersion je confirme est un
moment clé
avec et la dispersion est un est un
phénomène plutôt long c'est-à-dire que
alors particulièrement ces six derniers
mois tout le temps des manifestations
étant extrêmement denses la dispersion
doit se faire vraiment sur sur plusieurs
plusieurs centaines centaines de mètres
ou sur le lieu le lieu d'arrivée il
apparaît effectivement
ça peut tout à fait être
utile de s'inspirer de ce qui se passe
dans d'autres dans d'autres pays
européens avec des message sonore des
panneaux indicateurs voilà des choses
d'une clarté
irréprochable qui permettent y compris
notamment aux manifestants de pouvoir
s'orienter et voir dans quel vers quelle
rue ils peuvent accéder à certains
transports en commun éventuellement ou à
d'autres à d'autres
modalités de mobilité
le je terminerai juste par le fait de
dire les pré-cortèges grossissent c'est
un phénomène qui enfin c'est vous le
posez comme tel moi je n'ai pas de
réponse c'est pas forcément une question
mais moi ce que je retiens de ce de ce
de ces six mois c'est c'est plus 55000
adhérents pour la CFDT c'est à dire que
il y a aussi des citoyens qui rejoignent
des organisations syndicales qui
décident d'adhérer donc de cotiser et de
et qui se qui se sont retrouvés dans nos
modes d'action pacifique et non violents
dans le cadre des manifestations qu'on a
pu organiser
je vous remercie monsieur Souillot je
vous en prie
moi je vais commencer par les
pré-cortèges parce que la dispersion
c'est toujours la fin
sur les précortèges je suis pas sûr
qu'il grossissent
en même temps on ne les comptabilise pas
et le comptage des forces de l'ordre
vous savez il y a toujours ce delta
entre les chiffres de la police et les
chiffres des organisations syndicales
devant on ne sait pas
s'il y a plus de monde s'il y a moins de
monde
le fait que les forces de l'ordre
s'éloigne du cortège syndical
ça attire aussi les gens loin du cortège
syndical donc on n'est pas dans on ne
veut pas voir où on ne sait pas
après ça sur dispersion
alors nous on passe le message toutes
les organisations syndicales le passent
au syndicat qui viennent avec des
militants pour manifester mais c'est
vrai que les les procédures y compris
sonores dispersion où est-ce que l'on va
et tout cela
il faudrait qu'elle débute presque plus
tôt en informant
puisque les organisations syndicales ont
directement le lien avec les forces de
l'ordre puisque c'est le ce que nous
avons déposé mais
sur dispersion à la fin tous ceux qui
ont rejoint les cortèges syndicaux ont
pas forcément l'information où on dit
par exemple je sais pas 18 heures
dispersion Place d'Italie point et après
ça
les allocutions les sommation avec un
haut-parleur on pense que
on entend pas forcément il est pas
forcément entendu ni quoi que ce soit
donc il se passe
les camarades de la police de Force
Ouvrière nous tenons une très grande
place dans cette fonction publique
d'État nous expliquer que dans certains
pays ils avaient des moyens sonores qui
étaient plus évolués que le haut-parleur
ou parfois la batterie là je suis en
cours mais là c'est l'équipement
des forces de l'ordre et du maintien de
l'ordre
merci beaucoup effectivement c'est un
point qui lors d'une audition nous avons
eu avec les représentants cette fois-ci
des forces de l'ordre
ils nous ont fait part du fait qu'il y
avait là des expériences à l'étranger
qui semblaient en tout cas
intéressantes pour pour éviter les
problèmes en fin de manifestation
monsieur Lucas je vous fasse la parole
donc pour deux minutes merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur évoqué
tout à l'heure le 10 mai 1980 comme une
belle date donc je vais poursuivre sur
cette image en commençant par saluer la
force tranquille qui a été celle des
organisations syndicales dans dans cette
mobilisation et tout à l'heure un
collègue du rassemblement national ou
interpellé de façon un peu un peu vive
pour que vous imaginiez ce que serait
des mobilisations sans fonctionnaires de
police moi j'aimerais que nous
imaginions ce que serait une
contestation d'une telle ampleur sans
organisation syndicale et sans un
mouvement syndical aussi puissant que
celui que celui-ci donc je veux saluer
la porte pour notre démocratie qui a été
cette mobilisation vous avez organisé
mais question sont de deux niveaux la
première sur les conditions de
manifestation vous qui êtes des
dirigeantes et dirigeants
d'organisations
expérimentées comment qualifieriez-vous
les évolutions de de d'organisation et
d'exercices de la manifestation depuis
quelques années vos rapports avec la
préfecture de police le les docs
différentes doctrines de maintien de
l'ordre et leur capacités ou pas à vous
permettre d'assurer en lien avec vos
services d'ordre un certain nombre de
missions et puis une deuxième question
peut-être plus plus générale celle-ci je
précise avant pour éviter toute
manipulation ultérieure de mes propos
qui expliquaient n'est jamais excusé et
donc ma question est chiante est-ce que
vous estimez que
il y a dans notre pays un rapport au
gouvernant au corps intermédiaires aux
organisations syndicales que vous êtes
qui ce serait dégradées de nature là
aussi à créer un climat de de mise en
tension et de violence dans la société
je m'explique nous sommes ici dans la
salle de la commission des affaires
sociales c'est assez savoureux de ce
point de vue là de vous retrouver ici où
on a senti que nos concit bien avec ce
sentiment qu'on n'était pas dans cet
enceinte capable de débattre
sereinement et jusqu'au bout de cette
réforme des retraites est-ce que vous
estimez que ce contexte là puisqu'on
évoquait tout à l'heure le 16 mars et le
49-3 ce n'est pas un hasard que ce
contexte là s'il n'excuse rien
évidemment des violences qui peuvent
être commises peut expliquer un climat
de tension qu'il a aussi de fait échappe
pour les organisations syndicales que
vous êtes à votre bonne capacité à
organiser le mouvement social je vous
remercie merci beaucoup là aussi je me
tourne vers vous mesdames et messieurs
est-ce que suicide des oui madame Liné
je vous en prie
oui sur les évolutions récentes donc sur
le
comment d'abord nous on avait fait
partie de des organisations qui ont
remis en cause le schéma national du
maintien de l'ordre et on se félicite
qu'il était censuré suite à notre
intervention notamment sur l'aspect qui
concerne les journalistes et l'aspect
qui concerne les Nass parce que sur la
question que vous avez posé sur les
évacuations effectivement c'est une
question clé et forcément quand les
manifestants étaient manifestants sont
assez là c'est la catastrophe donc ça
c'est le premier point deuxième point
donc évolution positive depuis l'arrivée
du nouveau préfet de police de Paris
avec des échanges on va dire techniques
qui se sont rétablis de façon
constructive entre la préfecture de
police et les organisations syndicales
puisque dans la question que vous posiez
tout à l'heure sur les conditions
d'évacuation en fait les conditions
d'évacuation elles sont négociées au
préalable quand on dépose le parcours on
négocie avant comment on va s'organiser
l'évacuation par où et comment et donc
donc les fois où ça ne marche pas c'est
quand ce qu'on avait négocié au
préalable n'est pas tenu
et donc il y a des fois où c'est pour
des raisons qui peuvent s'entendre ou du
moins se débattre quand il y a eu des
incidents dans la manifestation puis il
y a d'autres fois comme le premier mai
2021 par exemple ou on nous avait dit
qu'on aurait tel endroit pour évacuer
nos véhicules tel endroit pour faire
partir les militante et militants c'est
voie d'accès ne sont pas ouvertes et
quand on interpelle l'agent de liaison
on n'a pas de réponse ou la jambe
liaison n'est pas du tout en capacité de
se faire entendre du reste des forces
qui sont
dispersés entre diverses autorités et
sur lesquelles l'agent liaison n'a pas
d'autorité parce que notre interlocuteur
c'est l'offier de liaison c'est
important mais le sentiment qu'on a
c'est que parfois quand il y a des
situations tendues il a du mal à se
faire entendre
de par la diversité des forces qui sont
en présence donc il y a besoin que notre
interlocuteur et une autorité pour nous
donner immédiatement les réponses dont
nous avons besoin et puis prendre les
mesures immédiates notamment quand on
est assez qu'on peut pas évacuer les
manifestants les véhicules etc etc
ensuite
moi je rejoins ce qu'on dit mes
collègues tout à l'heure sur la question
du cortège de tête bon évidemment nous
on est derrière donc on a pas de
comptage précis et c'est pas nous qui
allons pouvoir vous dire est-ce que ça
grossit ou pas par contre la conclusion
générale c'est la nécessité de renforcer
les organisations syndicales et donc les
salariés l'ont bien compris et donc
grâce à cette mobilisation on a eu un
mouvement d'adhésion fort qui concerne
toutes les organisations syndicales mais
nous avons interpellé de A à Z dans
cette mobilisation les pouvoirs publics
et notamment le président de la
République sur le fait que les
organisations syndicales sont d'autant
plus crédibles que quand elles envoient
des alertes elles sont entendues or là
pendant six mois on a prêché dans le
désert enfin même plus parce qu'on peut
dire un an en disant cette réforme des
retraites est mauvaise il ne faut pas la
faire voter il faut pas la passer en
force sur laisser voter par Le Mans faut
négocier avec les organisations syn etc
etc et donc quand nos alertes ne sont
pas entendues et quand il apparaît aux
yeux de toutes et tous que l'action que
préconise les organisations syndicales à
savoir manifester et faire grève ne
permet pas de faire bouger les choses
oui certains peuvent arriver à la
conclusion qu'il faut faire autre chose
donc c'est pour ça que en terme de
politique publique nous pensons que il y
a besoin d'avoir des politiques
publiques qui ont pour objectif de
renforcer les organisations syndicales à
tous les niveaux dans les entreprises
les branches au niveau national et c'est
pour ça que dans mon propos liminaire je
vous disais que nous sommes profondément
inquiets par les pratiques de répression
syndicale qui sont de plus en plus
banalisées parce que dès lors que un
syndicat ou un salarié fait grève
manifeste ou n'est pas d'accord avec son
employeur
c'est un problème et on se retrouve
confrontés à des processus de
discrimination syndicale vous savez
d'ailleurs qui a un certain nombre de
rapports notamment les rapports du
Défenseur des droits qui montrent que le
premier motif de non adhésion aux
organisations syndicales c'est la
question de la discrimination syndical
donc ça devrait aussi être une mesure
d'intérêt général et donc si vous voulez
faire une commission d'enquête sur ce
sujet on sera ravi de venir sur les
questions de discrimination syndicale
parce que c'est un problème dans tout le
pays le fait que nous ayons encore et je
pourrais multiplier les exemples des
délégués syndicaux qui soient licenciés
parce qu'ils sont délégués syndicaux ou
parce que il font grève et pour finir
sur la dernière question sur le climat
social oui nous avons alerté pendant
toute la mobilisation nous continuons à
le faire
le président de la République le
Gouvernement sur la défiance profonde
qu'il y a dans le pays entre le
gouvernement mais ça atteint plus
largement les les
l'institution d'une façon générale avec
une défiance qui qui grandit parce que
les alertes ne semblent pas entendus et
parce qu'il y a un décalage aussi entre
les paroles et les actes avec de plus en
plus des paroles en haut disant tout va
bien il y a pas de problème de pouvoir
d'achat il y a pas de problème de
salaire etc et l'industrie va très bien
et que sur le terrain ce à quoi nous
sommes confrontés c'est à de plus en
plus de travailleuses et de travailleurs
qui ne peuvent pas vivre de leur travail
des usines qui ferment et des pouvoirs
publics qui ne sont pas au rendez-vous
de ce point de vue là donc effectivement
il y a dans le pays une défiance
extrêmement profonde et nous sommes
inquiets nous l'avons dit répéter je le
répète ici sur les quatre ans à venir
avec
en quelque sorte le couvercle de la
cocotte-minute qui peut exploser à tout
moment et donc pour éviter cela ce qu'il
faut c'est des politiques qui entendent
aussi le monde du travail et qui donne
l'impression que les salariés du pays ne
sont pas une variable d'ajustement et
qu'ils sont entendus par rapport à leur
préoccupations majeures notamment
l'emploi les salaires et les questions
environnementales
qui a une autre demande d'intervention
avertise ont été obligé de
oui je vous en prie
alors je voudrais juste poser une
question à Madame Binet parce que moi je
m'interroge sur un point
député RN vous ont posé des questions
auxquelles vous ne répondez pas donc
déjà je suis assez surprise est-ce que
vous nous considérez
comme des sous députés nous avons été
élus démocratiquement et dernière
question très simple est-ce que nous
sommes logés à la même enseigne que
c'est news
merci
oui je vous en prie d'abord je vois pas
le rapport avec ces questions et
l'intitulé de la commission donc là on
est dans une commission d'enquête qui
est en intitulé précis donc moi je
réponds aux questions de la commission
d'enquête qui a un intitulé précis et
ensuite dans vos interventions je n'ai
pas vu de questions et la CGT ne répond
pas aux provocation
je vous remercie je tiens une nouvelle
fois au nom de l'ensemble des membres de
la commission d'enquête à remercier
Mesdames et Messieurs les les dirigeants
syndicaux pour votre présence cet
après-midi et le fait d'avoir pu
partager avec vous et à travers vos
prises de parole les analyses de vos
organisations syndicales donc merci
infiniment pour pour votre présence et
le fait de permettre ainsi d'enrichir le
travail de cette commission d'enquête
donc
une nouvelle fois merci à vous je vais
lever la séance pour quelques minutes
pour permettre aux à l'audition suivante
de se mettre en place et donc je lève la